I study whiskers because they're just
the best
most mammals they have whiskers and
what's exciting about them is that
there's so much stuff that we don't know
I like to look at something that we see
every day and then find out really cool
and interesting things about them
[Music]
people when they hear about whiskers
they think immediately of cat whiskers
but actually other animals have much
better whiskers they're more sensitive
they're bigger they move more than cats
whiskers
porcupine whiskers are just the longest
whiskers I've seen the one I've got back
in the lab is about 45 centimeters long
and they move them almost continually
and then they kind of bump and move and
vibrate around over the material that
they're on so you can really see that
they're moving all the time
hi coaches
[Music]
it's very difficult to study the
evolution of whiskers because hair isn't
really preserved in the fossil record so
we have a look at this little hole here
which is called the infraorbital foramen
or with the holes
and all the information from the
whiskers from those sensitive follicles
travel through that hole and into the
brain humans are really quite unusual to
not have whiskers but we do still have
these whisker holes where our whiskers
would have been and also we even have
some remnants of muscles similar to what
we see in in animals with whiskers
whiskers are very much like human
fingertips lots of animals can move
their whiskers and then some animals
engage in what is called whisking so
this is cyclic forwards and backward
movements that the animals make with
their whiskers and we might think of
this as scanning so when we walk into a
room we might be looking around
everywhere trying to see all around us
and that's what these guys are doing and
the fastest whisking that I've seen has
been in Harvest mice which reach up to
about 25 times per second which is some
of the fastest movements that mammals
can make
the most sensitive whiskers are in
aquatic mammals lots of seals will have
kind of just under 2 000 nerve fibers
surrounding all of those whiskers in the
follicle and their whiskers are so
sensitive they can do this amazing thing
which is called hydrodynamic fencing so
as a fish swims through the water it
leaves behind a wake a trail of water
movements and the seals are able to
detect this and they use only their
whiskers for this
these are porcupine whiskers and you can
see that they're arranged into a grit or
whisker map so you have rows and Columns
of whiskers so they're very ordered this
same grid-like pattern can be seen in
physical structures through the brain
and our neuroscientists love this
because it means that they can actually
tweak one whisker here so a middle
whisker and they can follow it through
the entire brain to see where that
sensory signal goes and each physical
structure will light up and turn
foreign
whiskers are their primary and most
important scents so it's very very
important not to trim them they won't
hurt them but they'll suddenly remove a
scent so it'd be like if you blindfolded
us and then put us in a room and so
we've got to feel around to work out
where we are and that is what these
animals are doing all the time we can
see that when we look at rats and mice
that some of them will actually engage
in a behavior called barbering so this
is when we have a dominant individual
that will trim the whiskers they bite
off the whiskers of their family or
other people that live in their box and
so when they do that those individuals
will become more submissive so it
establishes this hierarchy within the
cage
foreign
lots of new technology and Innovations
firstly we could have a look at their
shape so the undulations of seal
whiskers has inspired for instance
turbine blades so turbine blades can be
extra aerodynamic because they have
these amazing undulations or waves along
them these could also be applied to
tidal energy as well then you have the
fact that they are sensors you can put
these sensors onto robots so then you
can have tactile robots or whisker Bots
and these could be really useful for
something even like a robot Hoover but
also to make sure that robots can go
into hazardous dark or complex
environments these are the environments
we need our robots to go into so people
don't really think about whiskers at all
you probably go home and look at your
cat or your gerbil or your rabbit and
you think oh yeah they're fluffy and
have whiskers actually what we're doing
is trying to understand well how do they
work and how sense are they and what do
they use them for and they think that
that's super interesting to find out
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
Subscribe button and click the Bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video